>>> IN THE EAR MORNING HOURS
YESTERDAY, THE CHRISTM TREE
OUTSIDE OF FOX'S MANHATTAN
HEADQUARTERS WENT UP IN FLAMES.
IT WASN ACT OF ARSON AT A TIME
WHERE CRIME IN AMERICA IS
ESCALATING.
WE COVERED THIS STORY AS A
CRIME, AND FOX COVERED IT TOO,
EXTENSIVELY AS THE CENTERPIECE
OF THEIR NEWS DAY.
>> SAD NEWS, OUR VERY OWN
BEAUTIFUL 50-FOOT FOX NEWS
CHRISTMAS TREE WAS DESTROYED.
>> WHO SETS A CHRISTMAS TREE ON
FIRE?
>> IT IS PART OF THE RAMPANT NO
CITY IS SAFE, NO PERSON IS SAFE
FROM THIS.
>> THE TREE THAT UNITES US, THAT
BRINGS US TOGETHER, IT IS ABOUT
THE CHRISTMAS SPIRIT, ABOUT THE
HOLIDAY SEASON, IT IS ABOUT
JESUS, IT IS ABOUT HANUKKAH, IT
IS ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT WE
STAND FOR AS A COUNTRY, FREEDOM
AND BEING ABLE TO WORSHIP THE
WAY YOU WANT TO WORSHIP, IT
MAKES ME SO MAD.
>> NO ONE CAN BURN DOWN THE
SPIRIT OF CHRISTMAS OR DESTROY
OUR RESILIENCE.
A NEW TREE IS ON THE WAY.
>> THEY LOOK AT THE LIGHTS, AND
TODAY THERE ARE NO LIGHTS
BECAUSE SOMEBODY BURNED DOWN OUR
CHRISTMAS TREE.
>> I HOPE WE PUT IT BACK.
I HOPE WE PUT IT BACK.
>> I HOPE WE BUILD IT BACK
BIGGER AND BETTER.
>> WHY IS BURNING CHRISTMAS
TREES NOT A HATE CRIME ACCORDING
TO THE DOJ.
>> FOR SOMEONE TO BURN THAT
DOWN, IT IS SO DISHEARTENING AND
SO SAD.
>> IT IS GOING TO MEAN SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
WE LOST OUR TREE AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE ANOTHER TREE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BUILD THE
TREE.
THE TREE WILL BE BACK IN NO
TIME.
IT IS GOING TO BE BEAUTIFUL.
AND MASSIVE.
AND IT IS GOING TO MEAN EVEN
MORE THAN IT DID BEFORE.
>> IF YOUR TREE IS REAL IN A
CROWDED AREA, THIS THING -- YOU
COULD BURN DOWN CITY BLOCKS.
BUT IT IS EMBLEMATIC OF A
CITY -- CITIES ACROSS AMERICA,
THEY'RE OUT OF CONTROL.
>> THIS CITY HAS GONE SOUTH WHEN
IT COMES TO SAFETY.
WE DON'T FEEL SAFE WHEN WE COME
TO WORK IN THE MORNING.
>> AMERICA'S CRIME CRISIS HITS
CLOSE TO HOME FOR US HERE AT FOX
AFTER A BRAZEN ARSON ATTACK
HAPPENED RIGHT OUTSIDE OUR NEW
YORK CITY HEADQUARTERS.
AND GIVING US A FRONT ROW SEAT
TO THE RAMPANT CRIME RAVAGING
DEMOCRAT-RUN CITIES.
>> SO COME SEE US, COME
CELEBRATE.
YOU FIRE BUG LITTLE BASTARD, YOU
WON'T KEEP US DOWN.
>> THIS IS DEEPLY PERSONAL TO
ALL OF US, NOT JUST THE FOLKS
THAT WORK AT FOX BUT ALL OF YOU
AT HOME.
IT IS RED, WHITE AND BLUE.
IT REPRESENTS AMERICA.
>> THE WHOLE LOBBY WAS FULL OF
SMOKE EVIDENTLY.
>> HE APPARENTLY SCALED THE
TREE, IGNITED A MASSIVE FIRE,
ENDANGERING HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
IN AND AROUND OUR FOX NEWS
HEADQUARTERS.
>> NOW, NO ONE WAS INJURED IN
THIS INCIDENT.
BUT THEY COULD HAVE BEEN.
THIS IS A SERIOUS INCIDENT.
IT IS INCREDIBLY SCARY TO FEEL
THAT YOUR WORKPLACE IS UNDER
ATTACK UNLESS -- YOUR WORKPLACE
IS THE CAPITOL.
THEN, ACCORDING TO MANY, MANY
FOX HOSHOSTS, IT IS NOT SUCH A
DEAL.
>> 100%, 99% OF THEM WERE
PEACEFUL.
>> YOU DON'T SEE PEOPLE HIDING
BOMBS OR USING BAY NETS.
YOU SEE PEOPLE WALKING AROUND
AND TAKING PICTURES.
THEY DON'T LOOK LIKE TERRORISTS,
THEY LOOK LIKE TOURISTS.
>> THEY WERE THERE TO SUPPORT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND DEFEND OUR REPUBLIC
AND STAND UP AND SAY I WANT A
FAIR SHAKE.
>> THE INSURRECTION AT THE U.S.
CAPITOL, IT WASN'T AN
INSURRECTION.
IT WAS A POLITICAL PROTEST THAT
GOT OUT OF CONTROL.
>> THE WINNER IS MIKE MICHAEL F.
>> WHEN THE TARGET IS THE SEAT
OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY, IT IS
NOT.
THE WHOLE OF CONGRESS AS THEY
CERTIFY A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
THAT WAS FAIR AND SECURE, WHEN
THE PERPETRATORS ARE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS IN THE THOUSANDS,
FOUR OF WHOM DIED THAT DAY, WHEN
THE VICTIMS ARE POLICE OFFICERS,
140 OF WHOM WERE INJURED, AND
WHEN FIVE POLICE OFFICERS HAVE
DIED IN THE WAKE OF THE ATTACK
INCLUDING FOUR BY SUICIDE, WHEN
FOX'S OWN COLLEAGUES HAD TO TAKE
COVER INSIDE THE CAPITOL COMPLEX
ON JANUARY 6th, FOX DOWNPLAYS
THE ATTACK AND IN MANY CASES
FLAT OUT DOESN'T COVER IT,
IGNORES THAT IT EVER HAPPENED,
JUST IMAGINE IF FOX HOSTS COULD
MUSTER FOR AN ARMED ATTACK ON
THE CAPITOL THE SAME OUTRAGE
THAT THEY DID FOR THEIR
CHRISTMAS TREE.
PERHAPS SOME OF THE ALMOST HALF
OF REPUBLICANS WHO THINK JANUARY
6th WAS A LEGITIMATE PROTEST
MIGHT ACTUALLY SEE IT FOR WHAT
IT REALLY WAS.
>> GOOD POINT.
THERE WERE MANY, MANY FOX NEWS
EMPLOYEES AT THE CAPITOL THAT
DAY.
>> THERE ARE.
AND, LOOK, WE HAD EMPLOYEES
THERE.
AND I USED TO WORK THERE.
AND I WAS THINKING ABOUT WHAT IT
WOULD BE LIKE TO BE IN THAT
BUILDING AND THAT'S WHAT IT WAS
FOR EVERY STAFFER WHO WAS IN
THERE, SO MANY.
IT WAS MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
BUT IT WAS A LOT OF JOURNALISTS
AS WELL.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE
SAYING THIS FEELS PERSONAL.
IT WOULD FEEL PERSONAL TO ME IF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPENED AT
MY WORKPLACE, FOR SURE.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED TO THE CAPITOL
SHOULD BE PERSONAL FOR A